en la Premier League Mientras tanto el
Manchester City luce encaminado a volver
alzar la copa hoy liquido tres cero como
visitante al everton y ahora se
distancia cuatro puntos del Arsenal el
equipo que había comandado La Premier
durante casi toda la temporada y que hoy
se dio 3-0 en casa del Brighton fue un
resultado con tintes sudamericano porque
por el visitante anotaron el ecuatoriano
Pérez estupiñán y también el paraguayo
Julio Enciso después de lo sucedido esta
jornada del City podría coronarse en
caso de una victoria la próxima semana
en el Chelsea o en caso de un revés del
Arsenal en su visita al nottingham Sara
dónde estuvo el quiebre para este
descalabro del proyecto de arteta del
Arsenal y este repunte del Manchester
City tal vez en el Duelo directo Yo creo
que tiene mucho que ver con eso el city
terminó ganando partidos muy importantes
incluso este mano a mano que tenía
frente al Arsenal pero es difícil
entender como un ente vivo como es un
equipo de fútbol no logra sostener esos
rendimientos como le veníamos viendo a
este Arsenal que sorprendió en las
primeras 19 fechas logrando 50 puntos un
un récord
nunca antes visto yo que podría decir
que tal vez la nómina del Arsenal es más
corta que la del City y esto en la en
los momentos de torneo en donde hay que
gestionar esos cambios en jugadores que
son relevantes para la idea futbolística
creo que le costó y por otro lado el
city tiene esa experiencia ganada a
través incluso de los fracasos
futbolísticos que ha tenido que le
permite tener también jugadores que a la
hora de tomar decisiones son momentos
clave como estos seguramente van a ser
más positivos sin duda lo que sí vimos
fue un Arsenal que le dio una o Nueva
Vida a la Premier que no solo generó
disfrute en las personas que veíamos su
fútbol sino también en los jugadores y
eso es muy valioso este ya es un proceso
de cuatro años el que arteta ha llevado
a cabo sin duda es un golpe duro pero
creo que deja muy muy buenas sensaciones
en lo que pueden generar nuevos
entrenadores en un fútbol de élite como
el de la Premier el justamente hoy
asumía la responsabilidad de lo sucedido
en estas últimas jornadas No sí la
asumía porque pues es lo que lo que
corresponde en este tipo de momentos él
no puede salir a señalar jugadores sin
embargo cuando le preguntan sobre el
estado físico de la plantilla que es uno
de los temas que siempre se tienen en
cuenta para este tipo para analizar este
tipo de situaciones él decía que más
allá de eso es lo que veía era que no
hubo rendimientos individuales en su
máximo punto por eso decía yo que es
difícil interpretar desde donde es que
desde Dónde se puede hacer ese análisis
porque él vimos jugadores como synchenko
como dodegar como martinelli que hoy
tuvo que retirarse del campo de juego
que tal vez en estos momentos clave No
tuvieron ese brillo que que en esa
primera vuelta y tiene que ver con eso
con la experiencia de llegar a este tipo
de momentos y sobre todo pues seguir
creyendo en un proyecto que creo que eso
sí lo tiene el Arsenal el Manchester
City está atendiendo dos porque este fin
de esta semana juega también en en la
UEFA Champions League contra el Real
Madrid qué podemos esperarnos de este
partido fundamentalmente tenemos la otra
semifinal Milán inter pero
particularmente de este contra contra
Real Madrid qué podemos esperar Yo
espero un partidazo como fue el partido
de ida y me llamó mucho la atención hoy
en día que se habla tanto de datos y de
estadística que las probabilidades estén
60% a favor de un triunfo del City
porque lo que vivimos es que el Real
Madrid tiene muchísimas condiciones para
este tipo de partidos y una idea de
juego muy clara vimos un Carlo ancelotti
que hizo modificaciones muy interesantes
incluso poniendo a Cross como
mediocentro un camavinga que si bien
está en duda porque tiene una lesión en
la rodilla tuvo un rendimiento
espectacular vinicius siendo uno de los
jugadores no solo más influyentes de
esta Champions League sino que creo del
fútbol mundial en este momento y por
otro lado el city que tuvo 20 minutos
muy positivos en ese primer partido pero
que luego fue cediendo terreno
creo que lo que ha demostrado guardiolas
que es un tipo muy inteligente un
entrenador muy inteligente para
gestionar lo que está pasando en este
momento incluso lo hemos visto cambios
conceptuales que no eran digamos
pensados en algún otro momento como
entregar la pelota no tener tanto la
posesión y empezar a jugar más un fútbol
más de transición es un fútbol más
directo le hemos visto este fin de
semana otro gran partido en la Premier
Así que es un partido muy difícil sacar
la bola de cristal para saber qué va a
pasar esperemos que sea tan bueno como
este partido de